the countdown is on for the first day of
school for clark county school district
students again it's on monday and
sending your kids back can come with
some mixed emotions definitely in school
district police want everyone to know
they want to ease your mind they tell
victoria saha they are taking all
necessary steps to make sure students
are safe victoria
safety has always been a concern
especially with the uptick in school
violence last year the fear continued
from the shooting in uvalde texas i
spoke with school police and they are
ready to handle any situation on campus
the first day of school will look
different this year for all school
campuses you will notice a single point
entry for students staff and visitors to
ensure that intruders do not get in
through any doors lieutenant brian zink
with school district police tells me his
team has taken this summer to reflect on
the uvalde school massacre and sent 18
officers to get additional training
against active shooters or terrorist
attacks all of our officers know exactly
what their duties and responsibilities
are if there's ever an unfortunate
active assailant or active shooter type
of event on our campus our officers are
trained every single jurisdiction we
work hand in hand also new this year
school police received a set of 42
master keys that work for various
schools just in case they need to enter
right away this was a big issue in
uvalde where officers claimed they
couldn't get into the classroom until a
janitor unlocked the door i would hate
to think that anything like that would
happen here in las vegas
school police also want to remind you
that they will have k-9 officers
conducting random checks in schools
students will be able to be required to
exit the classroom while leaving their
backpacks behind so the dogs can check
them if a student is caught with a gun
it's an automatic arrest denise